hello rejects is correct here with my
teacher from class Kimberley Big C you
said at that time and the last time you
made me say I know I was trying to
something confusion yeah that's the
thing when I do some other takes yes
anytime I do another take you have
learning that about me in class
different every time the same thing
while and it's coming out really soon I
caught an early screening of Lal Island
yeah yeah fun in Switzerland hands-down
my favorite film of the year I've seen
all the big a old ones and it's my
favorite film of the year thus far so I
thought we should do a video today of
top five Ryan Gosling performances are
really hard it's hard he's got a lot of
great films out there I'm not including
lala land on this list specifically
because it's like this is just pre
Lowell is to entice you to go watch lala
land I'll kick this list off for my
number five choice I'm choosing the
movie Half Nelson I'm assuming is
probably gonna be on your list somewhere
to Half Nelson is the only movie I think
Ryan Gosling has got at an Oscar
nomination for it's a great movie I saw
it on Netflix man a teacher struggling
with drug addiction and it's just really
like gritty character study about this
relationship any forms of this like
student as well and Ryan Gosling if
there's one man who looks comfortable in
depression it is this guy what I love
about Ryan Gosling just in general is he
looks like the most relaxed actor I've
ever seen on camera yeah his shoulders
are just like down here like so chill
all the time just looks like so
comfortable he's great at what he does
yeah and that's a that's an amazing film
and actually one of the first films that
I watch because I didn't necessarily
know who he was at that time I think it
was like 2005 that made me go who is
this persona and start looking up into
his movies that came after that really
cuz he he really nailed it in this movie
and the relationship between him and the
student which is so lovely and pure but
then it sort of is looked at as
inappropriate by the people around them
but but the way that they kind of save
each other is
it's a beautiful phone it's a great
beauty that's hard to watch me hard to
watch movie what's your number five my
number five wait I'm not sure if five
being my favorite or five being no
number one is or what is my favorite
yeah okay it's not usually how list work
no what's your number one choice yeah
yeah that makes a lot more sense yeah I
think five is the highest number
therefore more powerful therefore the
more but that's a great technical or
shoot yeah okay so I'm gonna go with
that Lars and the real girl Lars and the
real girl or that's a great one it's not
on my list but I really I really thought
about putting that on I love that movie
because the subject matter itself with
being in love with a life-size human
doll he's so ridiculous with a lesser
actor I feel like would not have played
as heartfelt and sympathetic as he
played yeah role because it would have
been just ridiculous I feel like any
I've not any other actor but a lesser
actor would have just made the whole
thing kind of stupid but he really
opened the door to sympathizing with
that character and and I believed that
relationship that he had with this dog
there was a subtlety to that performance
yeah backed with an understanding of
comedic talent that was the first role I
recall words like he's doing a comedy
like yeah but it's a dark comedy really
dark like heartfelt and people trying to
save him from himself he's so depressed
and this is the only thing that's making
him happy yeah this is another where he
feel like Gosling is the master of
depression never really labeled it like
that but he's depressed in a lot of
movies either he's very different I
think because he's not afraid to bare
his soul I don't think he's afraid of
bear his vulnerability yeah cuz he looks
confident
while he's baring his soul which is
weird cuz normally when someone does
that thing they kind of like hide away a
little bit and he can like still like I
don't know he's got that stares is
magnetic
anyway my number four is as one of his
comedies the nice guys I contemplated
between three of the three comedies I
know he's done Crazy Stupid Love Loras
the real girl the nice guys and the nice
guys to me was a real delight because
that character in there
he's another depressed guy but it's a
straight-up like it is a comedic
performance and this guy is not cool
he's not like same thing with Lars and
the real girl I feel like a lot of films
you know when he's sad and stuff he's
still a cool guy and nice guys he's not
a cool dude he's a coward he's an
alcoholic he he's kind of a con artist
the only thing you see about him that's
great is that he really loves his
daughter and he's overall like a good
person but he does illegal [ __ ] his
chemistry where Russell Crowe was
amazing but he really does steal the
show for me in it because you think like
Russell Crowe Ryan Gosling two cool
actors coming together and Russell Crowe
is cool but Ryan Gosling goes the total
opposite kind of role in terms of
playing a coward which I really really
enjoyed I thought he was [ __ ]
hysterical in it and the nice guys is my
like third favorite movie this year so
yeah that's about to the top of my
Netflix queue yeah it does it doesn't
surprise they haven't seen it it's
actually really disappointing I mean
you're my teacher I mean there's a lot
of movies especially 200 that have ever
come out well fair point and I have my
number four is Blue Valentine great
choice yeah three what's your for know
that no I did my five you did your five
and I did my four and you do your four
we're learning how a list works yeah
yeah you got one of your movies even on
my list Blue Valentine because this is a
spectacular movie and him and Michelle
Williams are like will forever go down
in history well except for him and
Rachel McAdams I don't know the couple
love stories yes this one obviously is
the destruction of a love story and the
notebook being the opposite sometimes
like the realistic interpretation of the
depressing like here's what happens when
two people who are truly not compatible
get together they went through the
wringer with that book is not [ __ ] I
just heard that it's so it's not as like
a profound love story for all that we'll
say the notebook is [ __ ] and we will
die a little it inside because we all
enjoy although I love the notebook as a
movie but I think like in terms of like
real life I just don't think these two
people would have been healthy for each
other in any capacity but that's why
they broke up but then they couldn't
stay away because their love they were
they were men some people consider that
toxic love or codependency depending on
how you view it
no that's what we do there's a montage
of them abusing each other and violence
why is Blue Valentine great again nobody
was beautiful in that relationship was
just so layered and so connected and you
see the whole story from when they met
to Wednesday the destruction of it and
all of the things that came in but I
love that I think I once tried doing one
of the scenes from you did in class it
was great really we're gonna talk about
that she lies when the cameras are only
number three for me is the place beyond
the pines have you seen this man I loved
loved loved
in that movie that's what I mean yeah
he's a depressed guy nobody's super
badass in that film but see I think his
depression there's like this really it's
layered in with this really like good
guy yeah I mean because everything is I
think in all of these movies is for like
the betterment of the kid or the girl
exactly to sort of rescue and save yeah
destruction of himself yeah it's not
black and white yeah yeah just go with
only depression I do love that filming
if he is like an antihero in a lot of
ways not bully but yeah I mean I saw the
movie one time in the theatre yeah he's
only in it like the first 45 minutes of
the film that's what everyone walked
away talking about when the movie was
it's like cuz I also saw it in the
theater he's only in like the first 30
minutes 45 minutes I'm gonna cut this
part of the video he's only in it for
like the first act of the film there's
three separate stories being told even
though he's the first story and 2/3 of
the movie proceeded after everyone is
only talking about how great Ryan
Gosling wasn't that film but I loved
about the murders and you see that he's
really doing that [ __ ] they do that one
long take in the very beginning whereas
like playing with a knife and then he
walks he goes up to the motorcycle goes
in the game you know he didn't do that
no it's really him it was really him in
them in like the cage doing their like
crazy carny motorcycle stuff and now I
love ya a lot of people compare that
role to drive in the sense like oh he's
a getaway driver again you know bad ass
kind of lonely the major difference for
me and the place beyond the pines was I
felt that character it had even more
personality and drive you felt like a
guy who was empty and placed me on the
Piscean feel like an empty guy he felt
like a guy who's hurt bad yeah you
thought he was fulfilling a void and
that's why he was doing all this stuff
totally it's easy to identify with him
you still got a lot of those great Ryan
Gosling stair shots the same guy who did
Blue Valentine yeah that to me was a is
it a very effective performance and yeah
loved a minute loved the man that's on
my list
wait that was not that was mine that was
mine what is that was
like a power plant this is ready right
here place beyond Pines right there Oh
says you have six movies well because I
figured you would have some of the same
I even have one on the back Crazy Stupid
Love that's a great one man I have to
have that because you mentioned it
there's a lot of great Ryan Gosling
movies like I went to Zion TV and I'm
like what am I forgetting
like everything ended up on my list but
you talked earlier about him doing the
comedy with nice guys and him in this
comedy is awesome and I love that he can
be in both places of that heavy heavy
emotional drama and still go on the ride
with him and then be this like
ridiculous character in comedic movies
and I mean he was sexiest [ __ ] crazy
stupid I mean be better than the gap
yeah my favorite I mean Steve Carell is
top billing in that movie people like
Ryan Gosling a lot before that yes but
everybody that was another one where
people like you stole the show yeah cuz
Lars in the real goal wasn't a huge
comment in the dark comedy Crazy Stupid
Love while there's dark stuff and it's
primarily a comedy it's like a good
feeling kind of film that was a
different kind of role because while he
tends to be confident from the camera
that was his most confident character
yeah yeah he's really good in the
romantic comedies because yeah and he
has just a way to make a girl swoon I
feel like he I don't you guys know that
even upon hearing his name so in a movie
where he actually takes his shirt off
and then he does the dirty Dan lift and
that's like his move like guys learn to
do that for real you should enough upper
body strength to do this so maybe lift
some weights or something I I do lift
weights
it's like when I benchpress I tend to
use like 10 pounds okay you know I'm
trying to go for more like a you know a
skinny you look like I'm like I've
achieved already
I'm very skinny obviously yeah no pudges
here okay see you belong he is he is
really cool that film for I know you
your turn my turn my turn what are you
gonna say no because I know what I know
the one you're miss a it's probably the
same one I'm gonna say he already sent
yours that my number two is something
you said array which is Blue Valentine
oh wait we can say the same one this is
mine this is my order share some of
these blue Valentine for me it's my
number it's you choice I sometimes
wonder if that's my favorite performance
of his that is one of the hardest movies
to watch it's such a difficult film to
actually sit through because the film
does a great great job because it tells
you the story of leading up to them
meeting each other and getting married
and it simultaneously cuts to the
destruction of their relationship when
it cuts to like them being good like in
the past I totally buy it you just yeah
you believe it you'll love them there's
moments or you're smiling because of how
loved they are and you completely forget
that oh yeah in the future it's all
gonna be [ __ ] when you get to the
other part when the relationship is
falling apart it's so authentic you can
identify with it the arguments they're
having are more than like a movie kind
of improv argument yeah so that was also
fantastic directing and they went
through the ringer they actually went
and lived in a house together
yeah with the kid - I heard where they
had to sort of explore must have slept
together yeah come on what are you
respectful of their talent and
performance I don't think they probably
don't know disagree I disagree
you don't you think they had something
the same bad sound oh you don't know
that got super into character yeah I
mean granted I believe they were both
single when they actually prepped for
this movie so it's not out of the realm
of possibility but they are
professionals Ryan Gosling Michelle
Williams are spectacular they're so
about I'm going into character
and their ability to not need to cross
that line in order to get the
performance that we saw I feel like as
an actor I would always need to cross
that line you know I don't think that
that's part of being an actor it's
actually it's not I noticed none of the
girls in acting class ever agree with me
on this whenever we're doing scene work
yeah I'm like I just seems like this is
a necessary part of our relationship
with you know I think he needs to have
the top again the guys either
whenever you give me gay roles what he
only give me Gables um he chooses his
own scenes hey cop yeah what about that
it's hard to watch what's the number two
choice and it's funny because it is a
movie where he could I'm gonna go ahead
and say maybe only I was like five lines
of dialogue
can you guess drive yes he's so mean I
need like doesn't talk and you would
brought it up earlier of like the Ryan
Gosling stare this movie it might not be
the greatest movie of all time because
you know it's one of my top five
favorite films of all it is so good and
you can't again can't take your eyes off
of him but but for different reasons
this time because he's just so cool and
calm and collected and like powerful and
intense and the car the driving like the
racing in that movie is I heard he had
to take apart an entire vehicle even
though he doesn't do much driving in the
film the director thought the knowledge
his character has on the car is so
important so I had to take apart an
entire car liked it's very bits and then
reassemble the whole thing I can't see
how that would be yeah he did that
official exercise yeah
well drive is actually my number one
choice drive is my number one favorite
Ryan Gosling film I had only seen The
Notebook Briard of watching Drive and I
like the notebook I didn't love the
notebook like I wasn't like I'm all
about Ryan Gosling he did a lot of films
that people were raving about it I never
saw and then and then he did drive and
then I remembered going on Rotten
Tomatoes and seeing it like everyone
loves this new movie that I haven't seen
a trailer for yeah I'm gonna go check it
out and then I watched it and I fell in
love with Ryan Gosling and I binge
watched a [ __ ] ton of his films
especially at the time
was out of my life to watch a character
I was one of those roles worse like man
it's just they don't do it in an
expositional way at all this guy is an
empty dude he's an empty guy who finds
feelings for like loving this random
stranger in his apartment where he
becomes a protector and a warrior for
her my favorite scene in that whole
movie is the head smashing scene in the
elevator because that's such a represent
that's a great moment of violence being
a big representation of who this guy is
you're about to kill the woman I'm
falling him I've fallen in love with and
here's what I'll do to you if you try to
hurt her and then she sees like that
monster that's that's capable he's
capable of becoming it's like a werewolf
moment where he's like turns into a
monster in that moment you see these
also like a boy on the inside he's also
like an innocent boy and the way he like
treats her and talks to her and the way
he smiles and stuff like he he becomes
like a child with her and I really love
and I really identify with that with
that kind of character at that time well
leave it to a woman to bring out the
best in a man yes yes women always do
that for me right mm-hmm
that's why I'm worried I don't know
necessarily always but but sometimes a
woman can bring out the worst in you
yeah yeah what when it's the right woman
it'll bring out the best yeah so that
was his right yeah cuz he was like a
robot before that
yeah sorry and to like love and to and
to have a purpose yeah exactly and then
he just started smashing heads y'all he
was just badass his [ __ ] that song
yeah very depressed guy it made me want
to get driving glows yes
instead way he walks to you is so
comfortable like I don't know how that
guy is so comfortable he practiced that
walk I think enjoy I think he he
actively chose that walk because it was
it was sexy walk like the Gosling yeah
the cackling all right what's your what
was your number one my number one number
one favorite Ryan Gosling performance of
all time but I'm gonna go with a
notebook really
the whole yeah is awesome yes every girl
dreams of a love story like that
and I actually put it on the back of my
list here because I was like wow that's
not gonna be my number one but we've
gone through so many and the lovely ones
and I didn't put them in order because I
don't know how to use a list yet
that notebook is what we have left why
is that your favorite Ryan Gosling
performance that peak performance like
the bad boy that does everything in his
life to get her that's a good she does
build that whole the movie itself is
beautifully written it's a it's a love
story to go down with the ages but he's
like charming and witty and fun and
there's no brooding in that movie and I
think that that character could have
easily be played not misogynistic but
that's not the word but like like the
brooding sort of cocky yeah you're
against and he didn't have that he was
just this charming guy that that you
can't say no to it's just me the
notebook is like what Titanic is for
DiCaprio like to cap the greatest movie
is great in Titanic but it's still like
when it's still great it was still the
camera it was still like a pretty boy at
that time to me and Gosling was still
like a pretty boy to me at that time
against a pretty boys I just don't
really care for pretty boys do you have
a love affair with Ryan Gosling yeah my
buddy Brian gosse's no Matt Goss he's a
man now though the way DiCaprio like
evolved from Pretty Boy into being a man
is this pretty boy pretty technically
yeah he's a pretty he's a pretty man but
he's not a pretty boy so is Gosling he's
a pretty man and they have to currently
don't have a disagreement this feels
like we do there's a lot of movies it's
hard to say what your number one is
because he's just he's kind of great in
all of them I have seen a couple of
movies that were like but I feel like it
wasn't his fault
yeah there's a couple movies he's been
in that aren't that great but there's no
movies I've seen where he's personally a
headline that I'm like oh this is just
not good cuz I've even seen like there's
one movie called like all good things
that he did with Kirsten Dunst yeah that
I'm like yeah it's like an okay movie
but I think he doesn't
good job you know I haven't seen him
where I haven't liked him or the
character yeah the film itself might
have not been over the moon in my brain
I've never seen him be terrible or or
bad jostling is the man yes all right
guys what are your favorite Ryan Gosling
performances YouTube questions if you're
new to the channel subscribe today
become a reject follow kimberly Biggs me
on it's Kimberly Bigsby on instagram and
at Kimberly Bigsby on Twitter where she
tweets and retweets inspirational [ __ ]
don't watch lala land in the theaters
whenever it comes out in December
hi I'm being paid fifty thousand dollars
to promote it right now so yeah we yeah
this video won't make enough views to
warrant that kind of money but I need a
job change yeah I need this up
attempting to be in the movies and just
review just review them okay you way
more way more chances talk about why why
they're cool all right Don Tomasello
take care